bonjour euh je suis là clementina leur
pause ouvert en soirée normale qui
devrait reprendre cette veste est trop
bien à temps mais et jérôme genre de
vine cette veste est complètement moche
ces hideuses le mec qui laissa il doit
avoir aucun goût en 2014
quand tu va aux toilettes dans le train
[Musique]
c'est un mec face pour recruter
maintenant ça va
[Musique]
quand tu vois du papier à bulle voici la
lunette avec les caisses
impossible de draguer et salut ça va
vraiment j'aime bien me promener dans
paris la nuit c'est vraiment agréable
on fait des confédérés rencontrons des
gens et des lieux
je déteste maîtres qui disent mot le
matin je m'habille n'importe comment
genre et fonce à faire un vague ou un
instagram vidéo en faisant de la guitare
on dit encore un peu vite fait comme ça
sauf que tu rencontres jamais appelée
mobile tchalla 26 ce pote qui te grattes
de la bouffe
je peux ouvrir les chips non c'est moi
avec sont déjà ouverts désole
aujourd'hui et un nouveau jour je vais
me prendre en main réussir ma vie je
vous fais un bisou depuis new york je
viens d'atterrir mois plus tôt que même
pas à new york
alors ouais je me suis trompé merde ce
qu'on dit avant un mcdo au sort mcdo ce
qu'on dit après jamais dû bouffer mcdo
norman rien je pense pas du tout aux
fantasmes des jumelles
exact la chanson à ne pas mettre quand
par exemple tu vas passer à l'acte
sexuel et tu veux que je dois être un
petit peu de musique c'est de la
minimale balmont seychelles m'amener
draguer à la renaissance versus draguer
aujourd'hui autre beauté transcendée mon
âme
réponse non plus bouder ces moments
gênants
bottes quand ton pote ce gros bâtards
veux pas te laisser la manette jouer
ouais bon c'est pour te jouer
l'addition messieurs c'est pas moi alors
mares nos enfants à l'école
[Musique]
salut ça va bien